[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
sorry I got stuck in that for like a 10
minute loop there okay so how do
everybody and welcome to let's play cat
Mario alright I saw yamimash play this
on the other day and someone modded it
so it was a version with him and it's
just like a crappy picture of him I was
that little cat down there and I I just
have to play it for myself because it's
just it's just too ridiculously funny to
pass up oh god okay so the whole game is
basically trying to troll yourself what
I was going to do through half of this
so anyway let's just carry on am I
supposed to eat that I have no idea I
only watched umm yamimash play a little
of it hey wait hi wait what [ __ ]
that's bull okay so I'm gonna get it ahh
I'm gonna go under the assumption that
everything is an enemy and everything is
trying to kill me
cuz what to do here it's just the most
ridiculous game I've ever seen them out
oh oh I'm almost a couple of faves bull
that's not very many lives for you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you this game sucks
Oh negative okay we're okay I mean who
made this game why this diabolical I
played a game like this before there's
actually is [ __ ] Oh seriously is a Mario
game that I remember a while ago that's
like just epic trolling it's just an
absolute [ __ ] that's the entire time
okay I think it's just called impossible
Mario if I'm not mistaken so and find
that for me I remember that okay how do
i okay I got a beep that one and then
get on that one and jump over okay
alright bear with me cuz I'm bad at
these type of games any sort of
platformer tag deal
so you there okay haha on the cloud
[ __ ] this is bull
[Music]
ridiculous Oh to go back a place your
mouse gah okay so don't touch the cloud
the cloud is a [ __ ] oh oh I remember I
saw yeah Viva it's like [ __ ] I saw you
guys beat the first level and I thought
I remembered all the traps apparently
not okay let's just carry on let me do
some commentary about the game well the
art style is obviously vector-based
graphics trying to imitate the iconic
niche that was the Mario levels however
as you can see oh this is a troll wait
oh I remember that I remembered it why
couldn't I beat it I thought like a
giant laser whatever anyway as you can
tell the feline nature of the main
character as an ant as a protagonist
against the obvious a world that is
actually the entire
antagonist blah blah blah blah game game
game game this games stupid how am I
supposed to do that
how am I supposed to do that how comic
ah how do I run isn't there oh like a
way to run up get down there let me die
there we go
Oh bull this is a giant pile of boy I
don't even know what's going on I'm
gonna I'm gonna like I don't even know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do it and
it's gonna be bad for this dodge don't
like these people okay so how do I beat
this later
I gotta somehow if I just stand on it I
don't know this game sucks whoever
suggested this owes me Oh while I'm in
here I know that I should never trust
myself
I'm obviously too stupid to handle any
good decisions in my life I need to only
take game recommendations from people
that are not me obviously I'm bad at ah
yeah
and I don't think I'm supposed to grab
onto that so [ __ ] you
what do I do what do I do wait hang on
[Music]
no dumb there's not good
[Music]
the music's gonna drive me insane just
like the Zelda music from that one
amnesia cousin dog just like the Zelda
music this music is going to drive me
insane I know you're all out there
judging me please don't like you could
do any better all you're like okay maybe
you're not this bad but you're still bad
cuz I'm gonna I don't even know how to
get into that my god I was there I just
didn't know how to get in the building
that's all that's what that was my only
problem that's my only problem I had no
other problems besides that one in
particular you're all enjoying this
aren't you you're all enjoying my misery
I can beat this I'm not I'm not dumb I'm
not stupid
I am awesome in every way possible
because watch this
[Music]
hahaha now how do I win you do I go to
the back end of the ah ah I did it okay
whoa ha ha I'm the greatest what the
hell is that I don't know some sort of
advertiser okay second level I'm gonna
be totally okay oh I remember
wha oh no what the hell is that do I
need that why did I eat that I knew it's
an enemy okay that is not it even looks
poisoned Oh No oh [ __ ] I haven't even
gotten in the level yet and I'm already
dying mother of the time is fair it's
not fair
Oh No ah bollocks Go Go Go Go Pro
[Music]
yamimash I hate you so much
yummy man I hope you're watching this
cuz I hope I hope I hope that you
understand the torment you put me
through ha
okay that was my own fault that wasn't
even part of the patrol gaming that was
just normal Mario mechanics but yeah me
as I hope you know ah o proneness but I
think I can eat that
Wow what the hell was that ah bro bro I
wanna see that Ken what the hell
happened there
oh and this game is to read a good ok ah
I'm gonna I'm gonna kill myself I've
already killed myself obviously so many
time Baba I'm gonna do it for real you
and your um this game I swear where is
it where is it where is it there it is
[Music]
[Music]
what am I doing wrong
oh yeah I'm making them I made the
choice to play this game at with ok ok
so the third one is deadly oh no oh no
oh no maybe as a warning since you're
all here and watching me you could be
like hey you're just staying silent
watching me suffer how dare you
I need this all right
Pro Mode pro mode engaged
[Music]
I'm so cool I wear sunglasses
underground yeah oh yeah yeah so pro
yeah stuff on that oh yeah you ready you
ready Brit god you're fake oh so pro
pedo cat pedo cat I think they're
actually there's a hole that's a hole
happy fun family of pedo animals in case
you all didn't know and I think I forget
what the cat actually is but is
something I don't know what though
stop pedo though it's just normal
ah there you are ah bollocks I should
have gone back there probably something
waiting for me to keep me from going
back but I'm gonna keep going forward to
screw everything about this game every
off [ __ ] ah ah ah there are so many ways
to die it's ridiculous it's just so many
ways to die Boing Boing I bet there's
some guy that can do this like if you
ever watch the speedruns of Mario how
about there's some guy that can do the
exact same thing to this one and he's
just like completely ridiculous like
instantaneous every single day oh it's
not oh farm it again to that checkpoint
nothing you can do can stop me except
that that can stop me that'll that will
stop me pretty good one more try oh
there's the war
the worst I mean I'm really I'd like to
consider myself as a moderately decent
gamer at least I have gusto and panache
there's another one are there just
infinite cats
hi there are not unless I was just this
way all right Pro Mode disengaged
do I look weird without my glass here
yeah okay alright promo disengage let's
die again ah second uh follow me
[Music]
screw you Jesus and bull anymore
oh no way buddy oh fudge nutters Oh Oh
bollocks how am I gonna get through
there I don't even know
oh it's like ah oh you I was gonna go
away ah I was gonna go away who's gonna
go away alright you know what
I challenge any one of you out there to
play this game and try to beat it just
just try just try to beat it I dare you
I double dare you
[Music]
I want to touch it
[Music]
what did it do
oh this is just impossible this isn't
even Troy this is just I can tell this
is impossible
oh how did I make that what you're
joking me no I'm done no no I'm done I'm
not ragequitting or anything I'm not
quitting because I'm yo mad I'm just ha
I'm not time you know oh man oh I wanted
to do more but ah man ass this sucks
alright I have to pick this up at a
later date oh I'm so disappointed okay
so
ah man links in the description below
for all you guys so on try it
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
oh god I cannot lose this now I'm gonna
win what the hell happened in the last